Générique
...
Musique pop-rock
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans votre magazine de l'éducation.
Comment s'organisent les journées
des 12 millions d'élèves qui,
chaque matin, se rendent en cours
et quelles sont les méthodes
des enseignants ?
Ne bougez pas,
vous allez tout savoir
avec "Liberté, égalité, scolarité",
dont voici tout de suite
le sommaire.
-Le dispositif Ulis,
où comment inclure dans l'école
les enfants souffrant de handicap ?
On est allé voir comment ça marche
dans un collège de l'Allier.
Il existe 300 internats
d'excellence
en France offrant aux élèves
un environnement
privilégié pour mieux étudier.
Encadrés tous les soirs
du lundi au vendredi,
pour un avenir meilleur.
Transformer la cour
de récré bétonnée
en oasis,
c'est ce que propose
une association
en écoles parisiennes
et ce sont les élèves
qui sont les mieux placés
pour dessiner la cour
de leurs rêves.
Et enfin, retour en archives
sur les cours d'éducation civique.
Vous verrez que l'enseignement
des valeurs de la République
a bien évolué au fil des ans.
...
-On entend souvent parler
d'école inclusive
sans toujours savoir
ce que ça signifie.
Ici, au collège
Victor Hugo de Saint-Yorre,
dans l'académie de Clermont-Ferrand,
on accueille 13 élèves
dont les troubles et handicaps
rendent difficile
une scolarité ordinaire.
Tenant compte de cela,
le collège les intègre
dans un dispositif d'unité localisée
pour l'inclusion scolaire,
un dispositif Ulis,
comme il en existe 10 272
sur tout le territoire.
Vous allez le voir,
l'objectif est d'en faire des élèves
parfaitement intégrés au collège.
...
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Merci de nous accueillir
dans votre classe Ulis,
spécifique aux élèves Ulis,
c'est bien ça ?
-Oui, c'est un dispositif,
les élèves sont dans leur classe
et moi, je les accueille
quand ils ont besoin
de reprendre leurs cours
ou de suivre
leur programme de maths,
français,
ou selon où ils en sont,
à leur niveau, mais on n'est pas
une classe à part entière,
on est vraiment un groupe d'élèves
avec un besoin particulier
et qui bénéficie
d'aide supplémentaire
pour pouvoir suivre un parcours
le plus ordinaire possible.
-Donc là,
c'est les petits 6e
que vous allez voir ?
-Voilà, donc nos 6e
qui ont besoin de revoir
la physique, comprendre
l'alternance jour/nuit,
et les saisons.
Là, comme on a le soleil de ce côté,
ça fait la lumière ici,
donc nous, on est
dans la nuit.
Après, ça tourne,
là, du coup, ça va être le...
-Midi.
-Par exemple le midi,
c'est le jour,
et la Terre, hop,
elle tourne, elle tourne,
vas-y, ça tourne,
ça tourne, ça tourne.
Super, elle tourne autour du soleil.
Ca va ?
Et est-ce que vous savez
en combien de temps
elle tourne autour du soleil ?
-En 24 heures ?
-Non,
24 heures, c'est sur elle-même.
Mais pour faire
tout le tour du soleil ?
Il est énorme, notre soleil !
Faut pas l'oublier, c'est immense.
Combien de temps la Terre va
mettre de temps
pour faire le tour ?
-Je l'ai oublié.
-Elle va mettre un an.
Allez, vous avez bien fait
le soleil et la Terre.
Est-ce que vous avez mieux
compris ce qui se passe
dans notre système solaire ? Oui ?
-Pour qu'on comprenne
ce qui se passe, avec les 6e,
là, vous faites face
à quels types de handicap ?
-On est sur des troubles cognitifs,
donc on va avoir
des dysfonctionnements
de la mémoire, de l'attention,
de la concentration,
on va aussi avoir des troubles
dysorthographiques, dyslexiques,
plus ou moins handicapants,
et on a aussi un élève,
donc, qui a du trouble
du spectre autistique.
-Est-ce que vous,
dans votre formation,
vous avez donc appris,
acquis des choses spécifiques
pour faire face à ce type
de difficultés ?
Vous n'êtes pas une professeure
comme les autres ?
-Non, j'ai une certification
supplémentaire,
donc je suis enseignante
spécialisée
depuis 15 ans, maintenant,
dans les troubles cognitifs.
Sans être des psychologues,
on use de stratagèmes pour réussir
à les aider à dépasser ça
pour qu'ils soient plus à l'aise.
Je vais m'assurer,
un petit peu,
si vous avez réussi à mémoriser
un petit peu plus.
-Oui, on a fait sans modèle.
-C'est pas vrai ? Super !
-Est-ce que vous l'aimez bien,
le cours avec madame Louis ?
-Oui.
-Vous la voyez combien de fois
par semaine ?
-Euh, je sais pas.
-Beaucoup ?
-Je regarde sur mon cahier.
-Non, t'embête pas,
plusieurs fois par semaine,
en tout cas ?
-Le lundi, on se voit
trois heures, le matin.
-D'accord. Là, le mardi, une heure.
Si je vous dis Ulis,
vous savez ce que c'est,
ou pas du tout ?
-Oui.
-Oui, c'est quoi ?
-C'est ceux qui aident les enfants
qui ont des difficultés.
-Exactement.
Et après,
quand vous avez fini
le cours avec madame Louis,
vous allez où ?
-En récréation ou à un autre cours.
-C'est avec les autres élèves ?
-Oui.
-OK, et comment ça se passe,
avec les autres ?
-Bien.
-Du coup, là, vous les libérez.
-Oui.
-Et ils vont retrouver
leur classe ordinaire.
-Tout à fait, ils vont retrouver
leur classe de 6e A,
à la sonnerie, c'est la récré,
et après, vous avez une heure
d'EPS avec monsieur Le Goff,
et votre classe
ordinaire, d'accord ?
...
-Aujourd'hui,
on n'a qu'une heure,
on va pas faire
beaucoup de choses nouvelles,
nos petits parcours
pour se réveiller, venez.
Dedans, dehors,
dedans, dehors.
C'est presque ça.
Finis celui-là
et je viens t'aider là.
Regarde,
toute petite différence,
un, deux, trois,
t'essaies ?
Un, deux, trois, un, deux, trois,
ça y est, t'as le rythme !
Comment ça se fait ?
Tu le serres pas assez ?
-C'est aussi ce genre
d'attentions,
que vous avez
un petit peu en plus ?
-Oui, c'est différent.
Les enfants de cet âge...
-Ils savent faire
leurs lacets ?
-Oui, plus.
-Vous adaptez vos cours
ou pas spécialement ?
-J'adapte pas les cours.
-Vous suivez le programme.
-Ouais, c'est plus dans la façon
de faire passer les consignes.
Ce que j'ai pas besoin de dire
à la plupart des élèves,
je vais plutôt trouver
d'autres façons d'expliquer
comment faire avec ces élèves-là.
Vas-y, Mélanie, ça marche !
Mais ça marche !
-T'aimes bien quand
on t'explique, aussi,
quand Eva t'explique ?
-Oui.
-C'est plus facile,
parfois ?
Ouais ?
-La classe, tout le monde
aide tout le monde,
c'est une meilleure ambiance.
-Oui, OK,
et tu fais ça naturellement
ou parfois les profs
vous disent qu'il faut aider ?
-C'est quand je vois
que Mélanie y arrive pas trop.
...
-Parfait,
l'électrique.
Révisez bien votre vocabulaire.
Schématisation, vous êtes
au point sur les deux.
On flèche le sens
du courant, qui va du plus
vers le moins,
à l'extérieur du générateur.
-Tu vois, l'iode qui est en haut,
tu as un câble, regarde,
tu as la pile, le symbole de la pile
et tu repars de l'autre côté.
Et ils sont où,
les exercices, là ?
-Je me suis trompé,
j'ai mis du côté cours.
(-Vous avez combien d'élèves,
là, à surveiller ?)
-Trois, un, deux, trois.
Y en a une qui est absente.
On les laisse se placer
comme ils veulent,
et après, on voit
comment ça fonctionne.
-Alors là, du coup,
vous regardez un peu
le carnet de...
Non, c'est le...
-Y a des devoirs à noter
et, pour Ajab,
l'écriture est très difficile.
-D'accord.
-Il voit mal et il écrit mal,
donc on écrit à sa place.
-OK.
-La borne +, elle est là,
la borne -, elle est là.
-J'ai compris.
-Et du coup...
-Comment vous,
vous animez votre classe
avec ces élèves...
plus particuliers, peut-être ?
-Alors,
l'aide de Marie
est très précieuse,
parce que c'est souvent au niveau
de l'écriture,
la prise de cours
qu'il y a un décalage qui se fait
et Marie est là
pour compenser ce décalage.
-Qu'est-ce que ça apporte
à votre classe,
d'avoir trois éléments
d'un dispositif à part ?
-C'est un apprentissage,
en quelque sorte, de la différence.
...
-On reprend le texte,
on va le finir, du coup,
on a fait juste la première
partie hier, voilà.
Quels sont les signes
dans le texte
qui nous montrent
que c'est du dialogue ?
-Les guillemets.
-Oui, très bien.
Et on dit quoi, en premier ?
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour, donc là,
le début du dialogue est où ?
-"Bonjour".
-Bah ouais !
-Tu sais pourquoi tu es
dans ce dispositif, toi ?
-Oui.
-Pourquoi ?
-J'arrive pas
à faire du français
et des maths.
-Quand on t'a dit
de travailler avec madame Louis,
t'étais content ?
-Non.
-Non ? Pourquoi ?
Tu préférerais être
avec les autres...
les autres copains
dans les classes...
-Largement.
-Ah oui ?
-Oui.
-Vous mettez les chaises
sur les tables avant de partir,
que le ménage puisse être fait.
Bonne soirée, à demain.
-Merci, madame.
-On a pu interroger
assez facilement vos élèves,
certains ne se sentent peut-être
pas vraiment à leur place,
est-ce que vous entendez
ça aussi ?
-Ah, tout à fait,
parce que c'est très compliqué
pour eux d'accepter de se dire
qu'on est différent
alors qu'on veut être comme tous.
On fait tout pour laisser
le milieu ordinaire,
pour qu'ils se sentent
comme les autres.
-C'est un autre regard pour tout
le monde dans l'établissement,
que l'on soit ordinaire
ou en dispositif particulier.
-L'affiche devant ma classe
m'a vraiment parlé, c'est ça,
c'est avoir un autre regard
sur les enfants,
sur l'enseignement,
on a l'impression
de voir le monde autrement.
Musique légère à la guitare
...
-Il existe plus de 300 internats
d'excellence répartis
sur le territoire qui permettent
à des collégiens ou lycéens
en difficulté sociale, familiale
ou économique de trouver un cadre
pour réussir leurs études.
Au lycée Jacques Feyder
d'Epinay-sur-Seine,
ils sont une vingtaine à avoir
choisi cette formule.
Quand sonne la fin de cours commence
leur vie d'interne,
un peu comme une deuxième famille,
dans laquelle on va se glisser.
...
Musique pop-rock
Merci de nous accueillir
au lycée Jacques Feyder,
qui a une spécificité.
-On possède un internat
d'excellence.
A l'ouverture,
on avait seulement cinq élèves
et aujourd'hui,
on en a une vingtaine.
Ils ont en plus
de leurs journées de travail
on va dire comme
les autres élèves du lycée,
ils ont des études surveillées,
encadrées, voilà,
et beaucoup de soutien scolaire,
puisque, voilà, ils en ont besoin.
-Ils ont un bâtiment
qui leur est dédié ?
-Oui, vous allez voir
que c'est un cadre
très agréable pour les élèves.
-Très bien,
vous allez nous montrer.
...
Bonjour !
Donc là,
on est dans la grande salle,
grande salle d'étude.
-Voilà, toujours encadrée,
en tout cas les premières heures.
-Tu te souviens des principes
qu'il faut pas oublier ?
C'est-à-dire que
c'est comme en anglais.
-Est-ce que toi,
depuis que tu es ici,
depuis la rentrée, là, de la 2nde,
tu t'es dit que tu travaillais
beaucoup plus ou,
en tout cas, beaucoup mieux
que si t'avais été chez toi ?
-Ca, c'est sûr à 100 %.
J'ai pas vraiment la discipline,
j'ai besoin de ça,
à 7h, je dois travailler,
et ça, j'arrive pas
à le faire chez moi.
Au moins, mon avenir est un peu
mieux assuré que chez moi.
-A la maison,
je sais que je travaille pas.
L'année dernière et là,
quand je rentre chez moi,
je ne fais rien.
Eh bah, déjà, en 3e, j'avais 9/20,
et là, en 2nde,
même si ça paraît pas énorme,
je suis remontée à 12-13.
-Si, c'est énorme,
je te confirme.
Comment t'as décidé
de t'inscrire ?
-Bah, personnellement, en fait, moi,
je suis quelqu'un qui vit...
qui déménage souvent,
et ça veut dire que,
cette fois-ci,
c'est trop petit
pour nous et donc,
je n'ai pas ma chambre,
je peux pas vraiment me concentrer,
et j'ai des ambitions,
je veux aller loin
dans mes projets et mes études.
Musique hip-hop
-Les filles,
il faut aller à la boxe.
Posez vos affaires
et prenez vos tenues pour y aller.
...
-Donc là, on va juste travailler
pour voir un peu
les déplacements et la garde.
Après, vous allez
vous mettre deux par deux
pour revoir des petites
techniques simples.
...
-Pourquoi vous proposez
autant d'activités sportives ?
-C'est essentiel
qu'ils se sentent bien,
nos objectifs, quand même,
c'est le bien-être.
Aller mieux, aller bien,
une bonne estime de soi,
ça importe pour le travail.
-Toutes ces activités,
vous les avez pensées,
réfléchies sur l'année ?
-On essaye de faire des choses
sportives, culturelles.
On fait intervenir
des associations, des partenaires.
-Sur la vingtaine d'élèves
qu'on suit depuis tout à l'heure,
ce sont concrètement
des parcours atypiques, cabossés,
pas plus que ça ?
-C'est assez hétérogène.
Parfois, certains ou certaines
reviennent le lundi
dans des états pas toujours
très faciles à gérer.
On a une assistante sociale
dans le lycée
qui a une grosse part,
qui reçoit les élèves,
qui connaît les élèves,
donc c'est aussi très important,
l'aspect social,
ce qu'ils et elles vivent chez eux.
Musique pop-rock
Exclamations de jeu
...
-La proviseure adjointe,
vous la vouvoyez.
-Si vous voulez la tutoyer...
-Tu me tutoies.
-OK, et ça pose pas de problème.
-Non, c'est moi qui leur dis
de me tutoyer.
-OK.
...
-J'ai gagné !
-Les filles, on va aller se coucher.
Par contre, les filles,
vous me rangez la salle ?
-C'est déjà fait.
-Merci, les filles !
-En quoi ça consiste,
d'être maîtresse
d'internat ?
-Du coup, ça consiste à encadrer
nos élèves de 17h20 jusqu'à,
on va dire, le lendemain matin.
-OK, vous dormez sur place ?
-Exactement, c'est ça.
-Vous avez l'impression
d'être leur nounou ?
-Un petit peu.
En fait, assistante d'éducation
mais nounou en même temps.
Si elles ont besoin de parler,
je suis là, en cas de petits soucis.
-Ca fait partie de votre mission.
-Et il faut un juste milieu.
-Ah ouais !
On est en mode petit plaid.
-On a un rite.
-Comment ça se passe
quand vous rentrez chez vous ?
-On se sent mieux ici
qu'à la maison.
-Ouais, c'est vrai.
-Le lundi, je me lève à 6h,
mais je suis toute contente !
-C'est très dur.
-C'est comme des petites soeurs,
je sais que je vais
être contente,
je vais rigoler et oublier
les problèmes à la maison.
-Ce sont plus mes proches
que ma famille !
-Les filles,
je prends les téléphones,
c'est l'heure de dormir.
-Ah, il est 22h30, là.
-Yes.
-Bon, bonne nuit,
les filles.
-BONNE NUIT !
Musique douce à la guitare
Musique pop-rock
...
-Voici la cour de l'école Jussienne,
2e arrondissement de Paris,
une cour tout en asphalte mais,
depuis des semaines,
les élèves travaillent
avec les urbanistes
d'une association
pour la transformer
en oasis, un projet mené
par la Ville de Paris,
qui vise à aménager cet espace
de façon plus ludique
mais aussi plus écologique.
Il est l'heure du cinquième
et dernier atelier,
venez voir.
...
Bonjour !
Alors, qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de faire ?
-On est en train de préparer
le matériel d'atelier maquette.
On leur donne un plan
vierge de la cour,
les seuls éléments à ne pas bouger,
c'est les arbres.
-OK.
-Et à eux d'imaginer
comment on peut
transformer la cour.
Ils ont réfléchi
aux matériaux de sol,
aux différents aménagements.
On travaille
avec un groupe de délégués,
les deux délégués de chacune
des sept classes de l'école,
euh, donc ils sont 14.
-Bonjour !
-Ouais, asseyez-vous par groupes.
Musique cristalline
-Y a pas déjà de la terre ici ?
-Là, vous avez...
Ici, un socle.
C'est votre cour.
A vous d'ajouter
tous les éléments
de votre projet.
-Alors, alors ?
Comment ça avance,
cette maquette ?
-Bien, mais c'est un peu
compliqué à coller.
-Tu veux que je te le tienne ?
-Oui, je veux bien.
-Alors je vais le tenir !
Comme ça, je vous aide.
Je vois que vous mettez de l'herbe,
vous mettez des choses un peu...
-Oui, parce que dans notre cour,
y a que du béton,
des choses comme ça.
Et du coup,
quand il pleut, l'eau,
elle peut pas s'évaporer
dans la terre,
alors que là, oui, ça peut.
-Ah !
-On essaie de faire
une cour Oasis.
-Mais alors c'est quoi,
du coup, la cour Oasis ?
-Bah, c'est une cour où on pourra
avoir plus de fraîcheur sans être
humide ou rester toujours
avec plein de chaleur.
-On va le mettre là ?
-Hésitez pas à utiliser
la colle en bâton,
c'est plus facile.
-Est-ce qu'on a le droit
de mettre, euh, une rivière,
dans le jardin ?
-Vous avez le droit de tout faire.
-On a mis des cabanes.
Les étoiles, dedans,
c'est pour le coin lecture.
-Ici, y a un récupérateur d'eau
avec de la végétation qui grimpe.
-Ah, ça m'intéresse !
C'est quoi, le récupérateur d'eau ?
-Quand y a de la pluie,
il récupère
et quand c'est, par exemple,
la sécheresse, on l'ouvre
et ça arrose les plantes.
Et la cour en béton blanc...
-Pourquoi en béton blanc ?
-Parce que, comme c'est blanc,
ça absorbe moins la chaleur.
-Du coup,
ça fera une cour
où il fera moins chaud.
-Oui.
-Expliquez-moi un peu c'est quoi
ce projet de cour Oasis ?
-C'est un projet qui est mené
par la Ville de Paris depuis 2017.
On veut qu'ils comprennent
les enjeux du projet
et pourquoi ça les touche.
On parle de changement climatique,
et notamment des vagues de chaleur
qui vont s'intensifier,
et comment la ville peut s'adapter.
La maîtrise d'ouvrage
et la maîtrise d'oeuvre
sont faites
par la Ville de Paris directement.
-La Mairie de Paris
finance les travaux.
-Voilà, c'est la Ville.
-Combien de cours pour l'instant
ont été réalisées ?
-A Paris, il y a une centaine
de cours qui ont été réalisées.
-Vous avez combien de cours, encore,
en projet, vous le savez ?
-Toutes les cours
vont être transformées
donc en tout, il me semble
qu'il y a environ
un peu plus de 600 cours d'école
dans Paris.
...
Bravo à tous,
vos maquettes sont top.
Je vais les regarder
avant de partir.
...
-Les enfants, qui veut me montrer
ce que ça donne dans la cour ?
Allez, venez me montrer ça.
...
Nina, explique-moi.
-Bah nous,
on avait proposé d'agrandir
la zone du jardin,
et qu'on mette aussi
des petits fauteuils.
-Camille ?
-On a décidé, de la poutre verte,
qui est là-bas, à la porte ici,
que ce soit que des copeaux de bois
avec deux tentes.
-Tous ces projets sont réalisables ?
-Alors oui, globalement,
dans le détail,
pas tel quel, on va dire,
y a des choses évidemment
nécessitant d'être revues
via les contraintes.
-Et ce sera réalisé quand ?
-Les travaux
auront lieu cet été,
entre juillet et août,
pendant les grandes vacances.
-Donc à la rentrée prochaine,
nouvelle cour Oasis.
-Ouais, c'est ça.
On en profite à la rentrée.
-Vous m'inviterez pour voir
cette nouvelle cour ?
-OUI.
-Super, en attendant,
je vous laisse,
merci de m'avoir accueillie !
Musique pop-rock
...
Liberté, égalité,
fraternité et aussi laïcité,
tels sont les valeurs
et les fondements
de la République dispensés
tout au long de l'année à l'école.
Ces cours ont souvent changé
de nom, de contenus,
ils se sont adaptés aux époques.
Retour en archives
avec le Réseau Canopé
sur des décennies d'instruction
civique et, comme souvent,
ça commence avec Jules Ferry.
...
-Respecter les autres, les écouter,
demander pardon, assumer ses actes,
tout cela n'a rien d'évident.
Des hussards noirs
de la IIIe République
aux années 2010
marquées par les attentats,
la formation
de l'élève citoyen
a beaucoup changé.
Retour sur quelques épisodes
de cette histoire.
Jules Ferry tape
du poing sur la table :
l'instruction morale et civique
remplace l'instruction
morale et religieuse.
Fini, la régence de l'Eglise.
Cette instruction
dans la IIIe République
comporte pour nous
un volet inattendu :
les exercices militaires.
Respect de la hiérarchie,
amour de la patrie,
voilà l'élève soldat paré
pour un avenir qui va se résumer
bientôt en trois mots :
Première Guerre mondiale.
Mais faisons un bond en avant.
Années 50, les exercices militaires
ont disparu et on trouve surtout
la morale en tête d'affiche.
Instruire est édifier.
-Patience et longueur de temps
font plus que rage...
font plus que force ni que rage.
-Et, en effet, c'est édifiant.
Années 70,
alors que les années Flower Power
sont à peine fanées,
deux chocs pétroliers
viennent heurter le pays.
De nouvelles problématiques
apparaissent,
des sujets qui ont
de l'avenir.
En 1977, sur fond de crise,
apparaît dans les collèges
l'initiation à la vie
économique et sociale.
De l'économie et du social,
la politique n'est pas loin.
-Bonjour,
monsieur le président.
-A quoi sert un président ?
-Quelle question ! A quoi il sert ?
-Au lycée,
il faut attendre 1999
pour voir naître l'éducation
civique, juridique et sociale,
qui s'appuiera
sur la méthodologie du débat.
Années 2000, tout accélère.
Le 8 juillet 2013, la loi Peillon
refonde l'école de la République.
Bienvenue à l'enseignement
moral et civique.
Et par morale,
on entend morale laïque.
Et le 7 janvier 2015,
attentat contre Charlie Hebdo.
En s'en prenant
à la liberté de la presse,
on attaque la République.
A compter de 2016, pour tous
les élèves, de l'école au lycée,
l'éducation morale et civique
s'inscrit au coeur
d'un parcours citoyen.
Apprendre à être raisonné,
débattre, argumenter,
développer un esprit critique sont
des jalons de ce parcours citoyen.
Toute la communauté éducative
est appelée à se mobiliser.
Si changer les mots,
c'est changer sa façon
d'envisager le monde,
ces dénominations ont en commun
une même ambition :
un peu plus d'égalité,
un peu plus de fraternité,
pour tous et pour chacun.
Et chacune.
-Avez-vous des questions ?
-Oui, on pourrait se demander :
entre nécessité et urgence,
l'éducation civique
ne fait-elle jamais autre chose
que commencer et recommencer ?
Etant donné l'importance
renouvelée des enjeux,
il faut transmettre un socle
de valeurs aux citoyens de demain.
-Je suis égale,
je suis "égaux" à toi.
-Je suis égale à toi.
-Je suis égal à toi.
Musique électro
...
-Voilà, l'émission est terminée,
on se retrouve vite
pour un prochain numéro
de "Liberté, égalité, scolarité".
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...